okay I was wrong Ed and Eddie's 1999. I
was right all right you're always gone I
already see that a bunch of these I
could have put on mine yeah exactly
hello we watch the same popular TV shows
yeah uh there's a couple I don't know
okay so starting from what these are
these are so famous this is literally
some of the most popular shows what's
this one this is TV show
except I just framed it right this time
okay okay so so I guess we don't talk
about Pete show yeah but I don't need to
talk about teachers Always Sunny Game of
Thrones Peep Show the good place uh the
original Justice League cartoon shinobu
uh Chernobyl sorry Battlestar Galactica
Black Mirror and Doctor Who I am very
surprised by Battlestar Galactica yeah
hold up what okay okay
why why why Battlestar Gala you've never
mentioned an interesting like sci-fi
five star actually I I've realized it
when uh making this list but I really
[ __ ] love Sci-Fi TV shows what stuff
you've never talked about yeah why have
you never like hinted at that what do
you mean okay this is the music is it
because that I already talked about
isakaya you literally have never given
inclination that you give a [ __ ] about I
would take you more seriously if you
stop talking about music you didn't talk
about Dune huh you didn't talk about
doing much I [ __ ] love dude dude's
great dude's [ __ ] great I think it's
weird I think it's weird right because I
[ __ ] love uh sci-fi but I just don't
like Star Wars in terms and that's like
that's like that's like whatever
you know
um so yeah walk is um
that's one of the few sci-fi shows oh
sorry one of the few uh television shows
that I actually got to complete when I
was in universities it's been a while
since I watched battle started Galactica
but I enjoyed the sterny the journey
from start to end basically if you want
a synopsis of the basic plot of
Battlestar Galactica it's a sign it gets
deep it's a Space Opera yeah uh humans
have colonized the Galaxy and there are
like 13 colonies or some [ __ ] like that
and then they also built AIS right AI
robots and of course the AIS had an
uprising where the AIS I believe they
destroyed 12 of the 13 colonies right
yeah and the one remaining surviving
group of humans they tried to find the
last
mythical 13th colony which is Earth
damn damn but uh what makes it
interesting is of course these are like
the last 50 or 60 000 humans that are
just traveling through space trying to
find this last Colony uh but of course
they're under run from the robots which
is like I think I believe they're called
cylons
um but the twist is that the robots the
cylons are so well programmed that there
are some cylons that have invaded this
Fleet right of humans but they're so
well programmed that they don't even
know that they're like a sleeper agent
right so and they look and sound and act
exactly like humans do and there's no
real way to detect them so basically
real Blade Runner [ __ ] huh that's a real
Blade Runner Yeah so basically it's just
[ __ ] sci-fi Among Us you know
Among Us is sci-fi I guess it is so it's
just Among Us you know what Among Us
it's just Battlestar Galactica with the
suits on okay how many seasons it's
Battlestar Galactic of the game okay
this is what I liked about Battlestar
galatica I believe it's only four
seasons and it finished it up yes it's
all finished it's a complete story
um but what I found really what one
that's the one thing I really really
liked because that's why I've rarely
rarely finished TV shows yeah uh number
two
uh is that even though they have this
you know tension between like oh who's
who's a human who's a Cylon and
everything like that what I really liked
about the show is how it took this one
group of qualities and really explored
some really interesting ideas about what
would happen if you try to govern these
group of people right so basically they
kind of created a mini Nation right and
they they draw you in with like the
Space Battles and just the pew pew pew
and all that stuff like that but then
what's yeah yeah exactly but what kept
me interesting interested was in fact
the politics the politics behind behind
the spaceship the space this last space
colony and like what happened between
how you govern all of the humans and
everything like that on and I found that
way more interesting than the PPP and
like the Among Us part of the uh part of
the show I mean visual services so far
visuals can only take you so far visuals
um it is just one of the best sci-fi
shows I've question then did you enjoy
Firefly
I have not seen Firefly okay because I
feel from if you liked Battlestar
Galactic I think you'd really like it
like have you seen Firefly yeah okay all
I know is I didn't finish yeah well they
made a movie called Serenity afterwards
which was supposed to be like the is
that the sequel is that really like a
sequel to it though no because I've seen
Serenity no it's not it's not a secret
what okay what is five flies about
because all I know is like a space
spaghetti western or something like that
pretty much I'm trying to also remember
what it was about to be honest what
shouldn't find I just remember it being
really good because like I fireflies is
that one show that every person tells
you to watch yeah every every Sci-Fi TV
fan will be like Firefly best yeah I fly
best and I'm like but it was right by
Joss Whedon is that a good thing or a
bad thing anymore I don't know you know
like it's that thing you know okay it
kind of piss me off anyway but I guess
next okay while we're on uh sci-fi then
Doctor Who okay okay because me seeing
that immediately I was like holy [ __ ] I
forgot this show existed
but more broadly Doctor Who in the
Russell T Davis era okay yes so
basically I'm okay the thing about
Doctor Who fans is a lot of them are
just [ __ ] insufferable right they're
they're like the they're like the modern
Star Trek fans of old you know I think
same thing can be said for a lot of
these shows to be honest
I mean if a Show's good in some way yeah
long running it gets insufferable yeah
yeah I mean but like that's why I like I
really talk about Doctor Who but like
I.E it's a good show it's a really
really [ __ ] show and I [ __ ]
this I I said Battlestar galatzka is one
of the best sci-fi shows I've seen
Doctor Who is the best sci-fi shows it
is I I'll agree with that yeah yeah it
is in terms of like TV shows yeah it is
by far the show that tackles the most
weirdest ideas you could ever imagine
and it has like what I love about Doctor
Who is that every episode is like kind
of self-contained right every episode
tackles a different idea a different
time period a different place in space
and time right that's what that's what
makes it so [ __ ] interesting but then
it has like an overarching plot as well
that you don't necessarily need to watch
the beginning of Doctor Who to
appreciate it
you can't because no one knows where the
episodes are because the BBC dumped all
the episodes oh really well because back
in the day they thought why the [ __ ] are
we need to Archive this stuff oh [ __ ]
threw it away so I think a bunch of the
original original original logical
episodes are on you can watch them it's
like lost media yeah yeah
it's probably never going to be found
sure yeah and like to me like Doctor Who
like David Tennant's obviously my doctor
but I all I really agree he's my doctor
he's mine
I always like Doctor Who and I watched
it yeah but I just never got into it
like I would watch episodes here and
there you know it was the Christmas
special yeah yeah I think I started with
like because because David Taylor was
the 10th season yeah
um and I think I started on like season
eight or season nine I don't remember
which one is this after like the who was
the doctor I don't remember whoever it
was before oh bless you whoever it was
Christopher Eccleston I would know his
face if I saw it whoever it wasn't was
it it was whoever before it was before
David okay that was Christopher okay
okay it was uh that was the first one I
watched where I'm like oh what is this
show and then I start getting into it
and then David Tennant Doctor Who like
season 10 where I was just like holy
[ __ ] yeah that's great liked an amazing
actor yeah like like the Christopher
Eccleston also amazing actor as well
yeah I just think that it wasn't Matt
Smith's fault it was like Stephen
moffatt's fault was it Stephen Moffett I
think it's Stephen moffatt which season
was the week left the BBC yeah I stopped
watching Doctor Who once I left the BBC
okay yeah he bad no loyalty to it anyway
the Weeping Angels episode is by far my
favorite yeah because that is probably
the most unnerving episode of Television
ever because like the the real beauty of
Doctor Who is I remember I remember
getting into dog two through Christopher
Eccleston and that was like when the
Russell T Davis era started
um and I remember watching like a few
episodes and I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
look at the monsters man look that's
that's literally this is literally the
worst CGI I've ever seen in my life so
I'm the CGI would make [ __ ] some of
the anime CJ it would make berserk 2017
look like [ __ ] god tier man that's
how bad the CGI was and I'm like this is
absolute garbage why does everyone hype
up Doctor Who but then I just like you
just keep watching and somehow the
writing is so compelling that it it
dances the perfect line between
campiness and you know just epicness
it's just great television because it's
it's something where if you just step
out for a minute and just look at it out
of context look at like something like
the Daleks or something and I'm just
like and you're just like why uh why is
this guy pointing a light at a talking
washing machine or extermining why is it
got a [ __ ] suction cup look [ __ ]
[ __ ] it looks [ __ ] ridiculous right
but that just shows how [ __ ] good the
writing is and the actors are of this
like Doctor Who world right and that
yeah there's just there's just a certain
magic where technically it is also a
children's show but it turns everyone
who watches it into a child oh yeah well
it turns you it gives it turns you back
into that point in life where you didn't
question things too much you just saw
something cool on TV and you're just
like wow that's that's that's scary you
know and yeah
always go to the [ __ ] Doctor Who
Museum in Cardiff yeah really yeah
because a lot a lot of uh Doctor Who is
shot in Wales oh really sorry and then
Cardiff they have a ton of like a big
Museum or something remember oh my God
my school used to drag me and I was like
[ __ ] hate this I don't like doctor
here I also have a family guy Museum I
also thought
I also thought it was really genius the
writing that they Incorporated I guess
for the TV show where like at the end of
each season like when the doctor dies
quote unquote like he's just like no he
doesn't die it's just another version of
him dying and that's just like a great
way to just be like all right next
season who who wants to be the doctor
yeah who wants to be the doctor I also
think it's a good way to like reset the
house yeah to one freshen up and it just
resets the ongoing story because the
thing is even though there's like one
there's one massive ongoing story which
is like the doctor tries to find his
home planet you know but then every
iteration of a doctor who has their own
kind of self-contained story with their
own characters their own Side characters
within their own self-contained story uh
I just think uh I just think uh yeah
David sounds amazing David is [ __ ]
amazing I mean he's just an amazing
actor and Jessica Jones he's insane [ __ ]
you know like I'm has he been in more
roles aside from Doctor Who and Jessica
Jones I think he does a lot of theater
yeah so I think he he doesn't do as much
TV I think he's theater trainer right
yeah
I think he I think he does a lot of
theater yeah as much on the side of uh
yeah he's really good yeah